soleil vous restez avec nous patrice
carteron va tenter de donner quelques
éléments d'appréciation sur la question
que chacun a la bouche y at il une
accélération une intensification de ces
intempéries ces dernières années enquête
agnès monteux avec alban nicosie la crue
du rhône atteint 6,7 mètres entre deux
ce qui ne s'était pas vu depuis les
inondations de 1856 1944 avignon déjà à
l'époque les inondations dans le sud est
font la une des actualités le palais des
papes a les pieds dans l'eau toute la
ville est noyé cinq ans plus tard ça
recommence autour de cavaillon et
d'arles les mêmes endroits qui sont
aujourd'hui inondés
toujours à la même époque géant maison
notons les habitants ont dû vivre
prisonnier pendant plus de trois jours
et depuis ça n'a pas cessé bien au
contraire aujourd'hui beaucoup ont même
l'impression que ce phénomène s'accélère
la canicule s'est plaint aussi que ça va
certainement y avoir un rapport avec
quelque chose parce que c'est pas normal
qu'on ait autant de depuis comme ça
qu'est ce qui se passe est ce que ces
sept opérateurs qui ont monté que j'ai
pensé et nationaux d'ici aux fêtes cet
été ce qui est sûr c'est que cette année
le déluge est effectivement exceptionnel
par sa durée plus de trois jours de
pluie quand normalement il ne plus
qu'une journée et par son étendue plus
de 20 départements touchés
l'explication une masse d'air froid de
haute altitude qui arrive du groenland
qui rencontre une masse d'air chaude de
méditerranée et ce sont des orages à
répétition sur un fond de 100 km à météo
france on dit qu'il est trop tôt pour
faire un lien avec la canicule mais le
réchauffement de la méditerranée va
effectivement changé le climat
ce que disent les climatologues c'est
qu'effectivement le réchauffement de la
planète qui va entraîner à la longue un
réchauffement de la mer méditerranée
provoquera sans doute d'ici la fin du
siècle plus de phénomènes de ce type les
puits seront plus abondantes 15 à 25% de
plus en hiver ces images spectaculaires
d'inondations animant 88 ou à vaison la
romaine en 92 devrait donc se multiplier
un mot encore donc patrice drevet a
plutôt l'accélération donc il faut
s'attendre à dos accélération et un
densification des phénomènes climatiques
mais pour reprendre un exemple 3
décembre 1976 après un été de canicule
et bien violente tempête un petit peu
partout en france
c'est pas nouveau ce qui est nouveau
c'est cette accélération cette
intensification tout simplement parce
qu'avec un très léger réchauffement de
la planète et bien les contrastes
thermique s'accentue et c'est là que se
laisser la clé était son plus chaud les
hivers plus froids et les automnes plus
humide
nous sommes en plein dedans et à quand
des palmiers sur les champs elysées dans
quelques années peut-être merci patrice
de finir sur cette note plutôt agréable
on vous retrouve tout à l'heure pour le
bulletin et puis nous nous ferons un
dernier point sur cette situation à la
toute fin du journal
la crue du rhône atteint 6 6 7 m en ce
ce qui ne s'était pas vu depuis les
inondations de 1856 1944 avignon déjà à
l'époque les inondations dans le sud est
font la une des actualités le palais des
papes a les pieds dans l'eau toute la
ville et nous allier cinq ans plus tard
fin mars par jour de châtelaillon
d'aplomb les mêmes endroits qui sont
aujourd'hui non il a su toujours à la
même épreuve plusieurs maisons notant
d'asilah seul mot con et eu à déplorer
les habitants ont dû vivre prisonnier
pendant plus de trois jours et depuis ça
va passer c'est bien au contraire
aujourd'hui beaucoup même la question
que ce phénomène s'accélère la can il se
peut aussi que certainement y avoir un
rapport avec quelque chose parce que
c'est anormal qu'on ait autant depuis
comme ça que ce qui se passe est ce que
ces températures qui ont voté que je
pense aisément le ratio depuis ce haut
fait cet été c'est bien sûr c'est que
cette année le déluge est effectivement
exceptionnel par sa durée plus de trois
jours depuis quand normalement il ne
plus qu'une journée et par son étendue
plus de 20 départements touchés
l'explication une masse d'air froid de
haute altitude qui arrive du groenland
qui rencontre une masse d'air chaude de
méditerranée et ce sont des orages à
répétition sur un fond de 100 km à météo
france on dit qu'il est trop tôt pour
faire un lien avec la canicule mais le
réchauffement de la méditerranée va
effectivement changé le film à ce que
disent les climatologues c'est
qu'effectivement le réchauffement de la
planète qui va entraîner à la longue un
réchauffement de de la mer méditerranée
provoquera sans doute d'ici la fin du
siècle plus de phénomènes de ce type
les pluies seront plus abondants 15 à
25% de plus en hiver ces images
spectaculaires d'inondations animaux 88
ou à vaison la romaine en 92 devrait
donc se multiplier